Drake had a good time yeah I think I
actually like watching it over it's just
funny because I feel like I was in my
head a lot of it but watching it over I
was like oh no that was actually like I
actually am really like proud of the
episode and I was like oh that actually
turned out really well and it's like I
actually like laughed at certain things
in it and I thought it was pretty funny
but and during it I was like oh my God
this is not this is just it was actually
just really awkward right and I think he
felt that during it I felt that during
it was a very like a couple of sip takes
that were real real downbeats I felt
like where like which one
um right before he gave it to you to
hold on to and you said a lot of cup
holder oh yeah I I don't even know how I
thought of that but people liked that
when you left the Drake interview did
you were you like do you think I can't
post this oh for sure I was like this is
I I was like dude you had such a moment
like you could have had something that
would have like changed your life and
you ruined it and then I watched like
once I finally he sent it to me and I
watched it over and I was like oh wait a
minute like there's actually so many
like good moments in this and it's like
I was like this is going viral for sure